[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de
télé fils voici les principaux titres en
images de ce 2 mars 2017
après la diffusion d'image de
maltraitance animale au sein de
l'abattoir doux dans une manifestation
citoyenne pour demander la
reconnaissance des droits des animaux se
déroule en ce moment des
contre-manifestants sont aussi mobilisés
ambiance électrique
emmanuel macron vient de dévoiler les
détails de son programme sur le terrain
ses soutiens chouchi se charge de le
relayer
hier à versailles gérard collomb maire
socialiste de verrey de lyon tenait le
premier meeting yvelinois du mouvement
en marche et puis être dernier volet de
notre dossier consacré cette semaine à
l'agriculture focus sur l'activité de la
ferme de viltain présente sur le salon
international depuis 30 ans elle
alimente également les animaux sur place
atmosphère électrique en ce moment du
côté de houdan voici quelques jours
l'association l214 diffusé des images de
maltraitance au sein de cet abattoir le
seul abattoir de porc d'île de france et
pour dénoncer ce comportement à un
rassemblement citoyen était annoncée ce
soir seulement les défenseurs de
l'abattoir ont aussi prévu de s'y rendre
sur place pour la rédaction nicolas
kirillovitch celle la manifestation ait
des défenseurs des droits des animaux
est elle toujours à l'ordre du jour
malgré la contre manifestation et les
risques de tension également
bonsoir nicolas bonsoir oui où ils free
toujours deux rassemblements ici à
houdan là qui rassemble du coup
agriculteurs producteurs et de nombreux
élus du territoire ils sont environ 200
personnes derrière nous qui défendent
cet abattoir ans et qui dénonce
clairement un acharnement tout à l'heure
ils ont même lancé des oeufs sur leurs
opposants si je puis dire des opposants
qui sont pour le moment un peu moins
nombreux et qu'ils défendent eux la
cause animale puissent qu'ils accusent
de l'abattoir de maltraitance envers les
animaux nous sommes avec l'une des
coorganisatrices du mouvement et les
messages qu'on soit hélène
expliquez-nous un petit peu la raison de
votre rassemblement est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite de ce rassemblement du nombre
de personnes que vous êtes
bah je pense que les gens vont arriver
encore on n'est pas
au complet pour le moment
on est satisfait oui oui satisfait
satisfaite après ce qui se passe c'est
horrible dans notre société c'est une
société complètement spéciste qui tuent
des animaux fait c'est c'est
complètement arbitraire il ya aucune
raison en fait y'a rien qui justifie
encore d'aujourd'hui de manger des
animaux de d'exploiter des animaux en
fait donc on est là pour aussi dénoncer
ce qui se passe dans cet abattoir de
houdan et les producteurs et l'abattoir
2 août en parle de d'acharnement vous
répondez quoi ça ils défendent ils
défendent le défendeur ils défendent
leur la profession je peux comprendre
mais après ils peuvent aussi se
reconvertir ya beaucoup d'études qui
sont faites dans ce sens là pour des
reconversions vers une alimentation
végétale là vous pensez pouvoir discuter
avec eux on a l'impression que le le
dialogue est un peu on va dire
impossible on veut le voir lancer des
eaux allant jusqu'à hier nous c'est
possible de dialoguer avec le très
rapidement c'est pas vraiment possible
non mais yahsat incertaine
certains éleveurs qui malgré tout change
merci hélène lesage et puis wilfried ici
le rassemblement est prévu jusqu'à une
heure à rassemblement qui qui n'est pas
vraiment entendu pour l'instant c'est
des g2 et puis les policiers qui
assurent la sécurité pour les deux
rassemblements voilà ce qu'on peut dire
sur ces deux rassemblements ou donc pour
l'instant
merci nicolas merci aussi à nicolas
baudens brille et qui vous accompagnent
derrière la caméra et puis reportage
complet à suivre bien sûr au cours de
nos prochaines éditions nous poursuivons
ce journal avec de la politique et cette
campagne présidentielle de plus en plus
compliqué pour françois fillon est
depuis sa décision hier de maintenir sa
candidature malgré une probable mise en
examen le 14 mars une partie de ses
soutiens a décidé de faire machine
arrière dans les yvelines le juppéiste
est karl olive maire de poissy a fait
savoir sur l'antenne de france bleu
paris et qu'il ne ferait plus campagne
ils demandent un changement est urgent
de candidats quant au président du parti
chrétien démocrate candidat lui aussi à
la primaire de la droite actuelle
députée des yvelines
il maintient son soutien par honneur et
par devoir mais il se dit étonné de
cette décision de ne pas jeter l'épongé
de la part de françois fillon en
revanche il se déclare prêt à lancer dès
à présent
la campagne des législatives avec des
candidats uniquement issus de son parti
il annonce aussi qu'il refuse de
participer au rassemblement pro fillon
prévue dimanche à paris et pendant ce
temps emmanuel macron trace son sillon
dans les derniers sondages qui lui donne
jusqu'à cinq points d'avancé sur le
candidat des républicains dans les
yvelines se tenait hier à versailles le
premier meeting du mouvement en marche
le maire de lyon gérard collomb
socialistes étaient présents pour
échanger avec le public les images sont
signés patrick jacques de dixmude et
dans les lits il faut gagner
emploi logement face aux militants
sympathisants ou simples curieux gérard
collomb revient sur les points du
programme d' emmanuel macron engagé à
ses côtés depuis l'été dernier le maire
socialiste de lyon se dit plus que
jamais convaincus par son choix mon
problème ce n'est pas les positions de
benoît hamon
je ne pense pas qu'il ait aucune chance
d'être demain au deuxième tour c'est
effectivement le porter la victoire est
le seul qui peut porter la victoire
c'est emmanuel macron voyez depuis la
gauche réformiste jusqu'à la droite
républicaine
nous voulons un large rassemblement
c'est comme cela que demain on relancera
la dynamique en france une détermination
partagée par son auditoire qui quelques
heures plus tôt à prenait la décision de
l'ue dei de suspendre son soutien à
françois fillon
tout le monde est bienvenu a en marre je
pense moi je personnellement j'ai décidé
dimanche world d'adhérer le mouvement de
venir à cette réunion et d'essayer de
créer un comité sur la mezzanine donc
voilà j'ai envie de me lancer pour que
ça bouge
j'en ai marre qu'on me dise que ça va
pas bouger personne n'était exclue c'est
à dire que si on arrive à convaincre
moi j'espère que quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui dit je vote marine le pen
pas dans deux mois
ils votent pour ou elles votent pour
emmanuel macron on parle aux français et
tous ceux qui ont véritablement vocation
à reprendre ce pays en marche
véritablement prendre part à cette
campagne qu'il soit lui dit du modem du
parti socialiste et et ailleurs ils sont
les bienvenus en marche dans les
yvelines en marche revendiquent 7000
adhérents le prochain rendez vous pour
le mouvement sera atypique
vendredi soir les militants se
retrouveront pour une représentation
d'une pièce de théâtre à versailles afin
de souligner leur engagement pour la
culture et dans le public plusieurs
figures politiques socialistes du
département et notamment l'ancien
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines robert cadalbert
écoutez moi je me retrouve dans la
méthode
quand on a fait vingt ans à la direction
de l'agglomération et qui ont fait
monter des projets avec des gens de
gauche et de droite dans la meilleure
façon de servir les intérêts d'un
territoire
je crois que je me retrouve totalement
dans la méthode de meuf chez makro
pourrait pas du tout dans la méthode et
les propositions de benoît hamon
monsieur benoît hamon était un excellent
ministre
ces deux machines et paraissait jusqu'au
bout dans cette dynamique pour
qu'effectivement le quinquennat de
monsieur hollande soit effectivement à
la hauteur elles doivent permettre de
contribuer au bon déroulement des
contrôles d'identité depuis hier
l'enregistrement par des caméras piétons
des interventions policières est
obligatoire dans 23 des 80 jeunes de
sécurité prioritaire en france plusieurs
d'entre elles se trouvent dans les
yvelines attrape plus précisément et
cette mesure semble plutôt bien
accueilli par les fonctionnaires de
police après lé polémique autour de la
ferté au écouter julien le cam c'est le
secrétaire départemental du syndicat de
police alliance il ya beaucoup moins
d'août rage de relever lorsque la caméra
et est mise en route par les
fonctionnaires il ya un côté dissuasif
sur les délinquants et les personnes
contrôlées mais je
dit nous on est favorable à ce que ça
soit de l'initiative du fonctionnaire
parce que la caméra peut également
alors lorsque les contrôles d'identité
se déroule dans de bonnes conditions
il n'y a pas forcément de raison de
mettre toujours en route la caméra 1d x
parfois la mise en route de la caméra
peut plutôt tendre l'ambiance du coût du
contrôle en fin de compte un voyage dans
le temps à présent il y avait 50 ans le
général de gaulle signait le décret
instituant le concept de parc naturel
régional la même année le premier parc
voyez le jour c'était le 1er mars 1967 à
50 ans plus tard il existe cinquante et
un parc naturel il recouvre et 15 % du
territoire français et pour marquer cet
événement du côté de chevreuse la
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité étaient présentes le
reportage est signée haussmann vente
dernier cinquante ans après l'ouverture
du premier parc naturel régional de
scarpe escaut dans le nord de la france
les pnr ce sont aujourd'hui 51 parc et
représente 9 des 14 réserve mondiale de
biosphère un véritable succès fêtés dans
le parc naturel de chevreuse et le but
est toujours le même mettre en avant la
biodiversité et l'écosystème des parcs
naturels l'idée n'est pas forcément de
couvrir la france de parcs naturels
régionaux mais aussi
de profiter de l'exemple de ce qu'ils
font les parcs naturels régionaux sont
des lieux aussi on peut expérimenter un
certain nombre de choses qui peuvent
servir après pour d'autres territoires
sur le développement économique sur la
promotion le tourisme sur aussi des
méthodes des savoir faire
bref on est sur un creuset de création
un creuset d'idées et surtout de partage
qui est absolument extraordinaire
et le choix du parc naturel de chevreuse
ouvert en 1985 pour cette visite n'est
pas anodin notamment car ils aident les
commerces de proximité comme ivy des
bulles un savon écologiques
confectionnés par une habitante de la
région ou encore la bière vol se l'est
de la vallée de chevreuse nous sommes
arrivés tout à l'heure à saint rémy les
chevreuse et donc à côté il y a une
petite faim l'ancienne
maison de barrières enfin de la sncf qui
va être transformée pour de l'accueil
touristique à l'attention du parc
naturel régional
donc tout ça ce sont des actions qui
sont menées les parcs-nature région
chacun a sa spécificité
parce que les territoires différents
mais des actions qui montrent la
pertinence d'être placé parcs naturels
régionaux sur des territoires en
difficulté et du soin des territoires
ruraux
d'autres parcs pourrait voir le jour
dans les prochaines années l'état verse
3 millions d'euros tous les ans au parc
naturel de chevreuse cette semaine nous
revenons sur les acteurs de
l'agriculture yvelinoise aujourd'hui
focus sur la ferme de viltain une
exploitation qui fournit le foin pour le
salon de l'agriculture et qui sur place
elle présente également vous allez les
découvrir ces fameux et yaourts le
reportage est signée nicolas cuelho vite
et nicolas gendry les vaches du salon de
l'agriculture en raffole le foin
fabriqués à la ferme de viltain à jouy
en josas un produit à base de graines de
tiges et de feuilles de maïs
réalisé à partir de la récolte de
l'année dernière 5 tonnes sont livrés
chaque jour sur le salon de
l'agriculture
et y'a rien à dire les vaches il est il
est froid il ap temps il est il reste
une matière sèche correct pour cloche
franceville et il faut que ça soit
consommé frais donc on veut pas aller
venir chercher sa du centre de la france
comme on est la ferme la plus près de
paris va ils sont très contents et nous
on cultive plus de maïs parce qu'on sait
qu'on va avoir 300 vaches au salon à
nourrir pendant une semaine en plus de
nourrir les bêtes la ferme de viltain
est présente depuis trente ans sur le
salon à son stand activités pédagogiques
et dégustation attire de nombreux
visiteurs
c'est vraiment un grand moyen pour
apprendre surtout le domaine des animaux
ce qu'ils mangent
elle peut toucher même si c'est interdit
elle peut toucher donc c'est très
agréable
on a fait beaucoup de jeu
on a fait beaucoup de dégustation on a
vu des animaux c'est l'occasion pour
nous de vaincre rencontrer des clients
des clients de qui achètent peut-être
toute l'année nos produits
qui ont l'occasion de les manger aussi
dans leur restaurant d'entreprise
et qui sont content de le retrouver ici
du cou qui voit vraiment l'agriculteur
c'est l'occasion de leur dire vous
pouvez venir à la ferme et une ferme pas
très loin de paris on est à 17 km venez
nous rencontrer
venez voir la traite des vaches à partir
du lait de ses vaches l'exploitation de
jouy en josas fabrique ses yaourts et
d'autres produits laitiers on a mis dans
le fonds de la confiture et par dessus
du yaourt légèrement sucrées quand on
mélange et ba ont fait soi même
on mange un petit peu diop natura promet
un peu plus de confiture etc
c'est un peu ludique confiture de lait
c'est du lait du sucre cuit ensemble
pendant
quatre heures avec de l'avenir
le lait se réduisent caramélise devient
marron et ça fait une pâte à tartiner
pour cette édition 2010 est la ferme de
viltain reçu une médaille d'argent et
deux médailles de bronze pour trois de
ses yaourts et c'est la fin de cette
édition programme complet à revoir sur
notre site internet grâce au replay sur
l'application mobile également
disponible sur votre tablette très belle
soirée
[Musique]